Also willkommen zur nächsten Folge von Fellow
Cast, es ist wieder ein Video über den Moralpsychologie-
Workshop, den wir gestern in
München hatten, und Nova, du
warst dabei. Kannst du uns sagen, wer du bist und was
dein Forschungsgebiet ist, also ich bin Nora
Hansel und  Ich bin Assistenzprofessor
hier am Lehrstuhl für Philosophie des Geistes
an der Fakultät für Philosophie und meine Rolle
war die eines Organisators, also habe ich
die Veranstaltung organisiert und ich bin
selbst aus philosophischer
Sicht auf Moralpsychologie spezialisiert, aber ich bin wirklich  interessiert an
interdisziplinären Ansätzen, also hatten
wir viele Psychologen und
Kognitionswissenschaftler, die an
dem Workshop teilnahmen es gibt viel Austausch
zwischen Philosophen und Wissenschaftlern wir
hatten am Nachmittag eine öffentlich zugängliche Vortragsreihe über Empathie
und eine Keynote  das Centre for Advanced
Studies am Abend, das von
Professor Ray Lankan gehalten wurde, sie ist aus
Cambridge, und ich denke, ich bin
als Organisator immer voreingenommen, aber ich würde sagen,
es wurde aufgegeben  Eine erfolgreiche Veranstaltung und für
mich persönlich und meine Arbeit war es sehr
interessant zu sehen, was die aktuellen heißen
Themen sind, an denen Menschen in
verschiedenen Bereichen arbeiten, so dass zum Beispiel Empathie,
das unser Thema am Nachmittag war,
in so vielen verschiedenen Bereichen
der Philosophie erforscht wird  dass wir eine Philosophie-
Präsentation hatten wir zwei Psychologen
sprechen hatten wir einen Historiker und einen
Philosophie-Philosophen-Wissenschaftsredner
hatten und es ist ein Thema,
das in vielen verschiedenen Disziplinen vorkommt,
aber es gibt selten Gelegenheit, sich
über Disziplingrenzen hinweg auszutauschen, besonders
bei Live-Veranstaltungen, also liest man Bücher  und
Veröffentlichungen anderer Leute in anderen
Bereichen, aber man kommt selten direkt mit ihnen ins Gespräch,
also war es in
dieser Hinsicht wirklich nützlich, also hatte man beim Workshop
diese verschiedenen Arten von Personen mit
unterschiedlichem Bildungshintergrund, okay,
genau aus verschiedenen Disziplinen, und
ja, das war es wirklich  interessant zu sehen,
wie man das so z. B.
in der Psychologie angeht w  Wir hatten ein paar Psychologen,
die sich auf moralische Entwicklung spezialisierten,
also wie moralische Normen sich
entwickelnde Kinder soziale Normen sehen.
Sagen wir, wo die Kinder verstehen,
was in einer Person vor sich geht, wie es
ihr Verhalten beeinflusst. Philosophen,
damit Philosophie eine der Philosophien ist,
die wir sprechen
Ich habe mich mehr damit befasst, wie man sich vorstellen kann, was passiert, wenn man sich in eine andere Person einfühlt, also war die
Behauptung, man stellt
sich vor, wie es ist,
in diesem Moment diese andere Person zu sein, also man selbst zu sein
, die Person so mmm  -hmm war eher
ein konzeptioneller Ansatz, und dann stellt sich die
Frage, wie Erkenntnisse über
Empathie philosophisches Theoretisieren beeinflussen
und wie philosophisches Theoretisieren
helfen kann, Erkenntnisse in den Wissenschaften zu interpretieren
, ob es eine Einigung oder Vereinbarung darüber gibt, wie Empathie sein sollte oder was
wir nehmen sollten
Ich denke, wir haben die Synthese nicht gemocht,
wir haben mehr gelernt und überrascht,
was auch immer auf dem anderen Gebiet
und mir vor sich geht  war irgendwie verblüfft von dem, was unsere
Experten für Geschichte und Wissenschaftsphilosophie sagen, dass Sie wissen, dass es
über 40 Definitionen von Empathie gibt, und ich
denke, es ist schwer zu erwarten, dass Sie in einem
Workshop andere Studenten wiedervereinen
, aber wie ist es vielleicht so so, was war
So arrangiert, wenn es keine
Einigung oder gesunden Menschenverstand gab, was waren die
breitesten Punkte wie das Ja, was waren
die Extreme in diesem
Workshop? Extreme, Sie meinen, wie Leute
, die weit von mir entfernt sind
Interesse am anderen
Feld sonst Leute, die Sie kennen Leute,
die wirklich weit auseinander liegen und denken, dass
andere Beiträge aus anderen
Disziplinen keine Rolle spielen,
sie wären nicht einmal daran interessiert,
an einer solchen Veranstaltung teilzunehmen, also
sprechen wir von Forschern, die es
sind  die bereit sind, die Disziplinarkammer zu
durchqueren und zu sehen, was da draußen ist, und
nicht versuchen, auf ihrem Gebiet zu bleiben,
danke für den Überblick über den Moralpsychologie-
Workshop, und ja, wir werden es tun
In der Beschreibung sind noch einige Videos
mit jedem Sprecher und auch wirklich
interessante Themen, die Sie sich ansehen sollten
, und in einem anderen Video haben wir ein
Interview mit Ihnen über Ihre Recherche, also
ja, vielen Dank, Ihnen
selbst